so this week almost every day we've had
sort of a follow up to the story that
started on Monday related to political
violence and the encouragement to that
political violence from the President of
the United States and I don't want to
redo everything we've already done this
week but as a reminder the overwhelming
majority of political violence in the
United States is perpetrated by
right-wing actors seventy-four percent
of political Rheba politically motivated
murders have taken place by the right
over recent history in the United States
right-wing extremism as we spoke about
with David Muir has been emboldened and
coalesced and has grown under the
current president and on Tuesday I told
you the story of a pipe bomb being sent
to target enemy as they see him of the
right George Soros well that was only
the beginning now similar pipe bombs
have been sent to the Obamas to Hillary
and Bill Clinton's home to former CIA
director John Brennan at CNN offices in
New York City causing a mass evacuation
of CNN yesterday a similar package was
sent to Obama era Attorney General Eric
Holder Democratic congresswoman debbie
Wasserman Schultz received a package
with a pipe bomb authorities believe
that they have found one this is more
recent sent to former Vice President Joe
Biden multiple packages sent to
Democratic congresswoman Maxine Waters
also a target of Donald Trump as a low
IQ person the San Diego Tribune
I believe received such a package and a
business owned by known left-wing
celebrity Robert DeNiro also receiving
one of these pipe bomb packages some of
these pipe bombs not all delivered in
the same way some apparently and a lot
of this information is still early
delivered by courier some sent through
the mail some had stamps on them but the
stamps had not been canceled by the post
office meaning that even though they
were stamped that it was not actually
sent through the mail and when you look
at the list and you think about it and
then you ask yourself who has been
vilified by Donald Trump over the last
few years out of that list well media
has been a target and both CNN and a
newspaper
leaving these pipe bombs president obama
has certainly been vilified by Donald
Trump and Donald Trump one of the early
sort of other eyes errs of President
Obama by making perpetrating the hoax
and perpetuating it perpetrating it and
perpetuating the hoax about Barack Obama
and his birth certificate and where he
was born
receiving a pipe bomb Hillary Clinton of
course lock her up
reminiscent of the campaign era chanted
yesterday even when Hillary Clinton's
name was mentioned at a rally or the day
before former CIA director John Brennan
his security clearance has been revoked
by Donald Trump he has become one of
these targets of the ire of the right
under Donald Trump so it's really
important not to allow people to get
away with this there's violence on both
sides and we need civility on both sides
know the both side er ISM I don't know
what to call it both sigh tourism is
totally bogus
this is right-wing terror . this relates
to luck directly to what donald trump
advocated people do back in 2016 Donald
Trump said Hillary Clinton's Secret
Service should stop protecting her so
that we can quote see what happens to
her Trump suggested that maybe the
Second Amendment people would do
something about Hillary Clinton if she
were to get elected president of the
United States and now Trump at rallies
seems shocked that the violence he has
been promoting every day for years has
actually become a reality and then we
have to address the elephant in the room
or I guess we would call it the other
elephant in the room the second that
these pipe bombs broke in to live
coverage of news all over the United
States and all over the world in fact I
predicted that the right would claim to
false flag it's right before the
midterms all of these went to left
wingers this is obviously fake and
staged in order to influence people's
votes in the midterm elections and as if
you needed any more evidence that
turning-point USA's Candace Owens is a
disgusting and vile person she tweeted
yesterday that quote I'm going to go
ahead and state that there is a zero
chance that these quote suspicious
packages were sent out by conservatives
the only thing suspicious about these
packages is their timing caravans fake
bomb threats these leftists are going
all out for the midterms now this really
appealed to her base she ultimately
deleted this tweet I am guessing someone
from Turning Point USA or someone in her
circle said hey you're basically Alex
Jones when you say this Candice and she
deleted it Pat but not before it had
thousands and thousands of retweets yeah
I'm not surprised it's a totally dumb
thing to say to a 0% chance
that means it's totally unfalsifiable
you can't present any evidence that
would change her mind yes that means
that her beliefs are not based in
evidence are they and that's exactly the
point I think which is that these ideas
are not based in evidence
twitter user Kevin Donahoe who does
communications for Florida Democrats
posted a picture from outside the
Florida gubernatorial debate and you can
see a sign there that says fake news
fake bombs and indeed this is what we
are fighting the people who do this and
the people who then call it a false flag
by the left word we have to fight all of
them and there's some element of
ignorance
obviously in even doing this like who
who thinks that the Clintons or Obama's
are actually opening their own mail some
of these packages were actually stopped
at mail handling facilities but of
course it is possible that something
would get through that doesn't in any
way excuse the seriousness of it it does
sort of indicate some of the ignorance
maybe on the behalf of the people or
person or people who are sending this
stuff so number one I'm ready to say now
as if I wasn't ready to say it on Monday
the glorifying of body-slamming members
of the media by Donald Trump the attacks
on media as the enemy of the people the
defenses of authoritarian governments
who killed journalists by repeating the
bizarre and bogus talking points like it
could have been anybody it could have
been rogue killers offers to pay the
legal fees for people who punch
protestors at your rallies
all of that should probably stop I think
it's a point at which left and right
need to say that and I saw Republican
after Republican yesterday on TV say
violence of all types is bad but we need
civility on both side know the
overwhelming majority of the violence is
coming from the right the violent
rhetoric is coming from the right and
they'll say but David anti feh through a
bike lock three months ago that's
anecdotal look at the data look at the
numbers yeah this is what we've been
worried about there's been two years of
rhetoric akin to this and this is what
ends up happening I'm surprised I mean
I'm glad it didn't turn out much worse
because it certainly could have and you
they're using that as well
the right is saying listen these were
very poorly made pipe bombs and it was
extraordinarily unlikely that they were
able that they would have been able to
explode or even that they were meant to
explode so therefore this doesn't really
merit the criticism that some people are
putting out there that is one of the
most ridiculous arguments that I've
heard number one these things were
packed with glass one of these was
actually detonated in a controlled
detonation and the fact that they hadn't
exploded mostly is not a defense of any
kind one of today's sponsors is
Skillshare which is an incredible online
learning community offering over 10,000
high-quality online courses on a huge
variety of topics first 500 who click
the link under this video will get two
entire months of totally free access to
every single class that Skillshare
offers you'll have free access to
courses on music art photography
business computer programming cooking
meditation and everything in between I
think you'll have no problem finding
courses that are perfect for you just
took a really great class on graphic
design which I know nothing about but
I'm trying to learn our show is giving
you two entire months of totally free
access to every course Skillshare offers
risk free if you click the link under
this video you'll have two months to
take classes on anything you're
passionate about classes taught by real
people who share that passion and after
that you can keep getting access to the
entire site for
than 10 bucks a month just click the
link under this video to redeem your to
three months of Skillshare but hurry
it's only available to the first 500 who
sign up